>> PRESIDENT BUY NOT SPEAKING
FOR ALMOST A HALF HOUR.
HIS SPEECH AND HE TOOK SEVERAL
QUESTIONS INCLUDING OUR PETER D.
ONE QUESTION, WHEN IT COMES TO
THE TERRORISTS OF TODAY.
WE WILL NOT FORGIVE.
WE WILL NOT FORGET.
WE WILL HUNT YOU DOWN WITH ALL
RESOURCES AT HIS COMMAND.
THAT IS FROM THE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES.
PETER ASKED HIM DO YOU BEAR
RESPONSIBILITY FOR WHAT HAS
HAPPENED IN THE LAST TWO WEEKS.
I BEAR RESPONSIBILITY OF ALL
THAT HAS HAPPENED OF LATE WITH
YOU AND, HERE IS THE BUT.
I WISH ONE DAY WOULD YOU SAY
THESE THINGS.
YOU KNOW THE FORMER PRESIDENT,
PRESIDENT TRUMP MADE A DEAL WITH
THE TALIBAN.
HE PAID TRIP UTILITY TO THE
12U.S. SERVICE MEMBERS DYING
TODAY IN THE ATTACK AND ASKED
THE NATION FOR A MOMENT OF
SILENCE THIS.
IS THE SPEECH HE GAVE.
BILL, YOUR THOUGHTS.
>> A COUPLE OF THINGS HERE.
I WILL GO QUICKLY SO EVERYONE
HAS A CHANCE HERE.
I THINK PETER GOT AS CLOSE TO
THE ESSENTIAL QUESTION AS ANYONE
DID.
SIR, IS THIS ON YOU.
WE HEARD THAT QUESTION FROM
PETER.
WITH REGARD TO THE FUTURE HERE I
THOUGHT HE HAD A FEW STRONG
MOMENTS.
I WOULD ARGUE THE MOMENTS WERE
LATE BY ABOUT TEN DAYS.
I DON'T KNOW IF HE WILL SAVE THE
ISIS TERRORISTS WILL NOT WIN, WE
WILL HUNT THEM DOWN, WE WON'T
FORGIVE OR FORGET.
THAT'S PROPER LANGUAGE.
HOW YOU DO THAT FROM OVER THE
HORIZON.
HOW DO YOU THAT WHEN YOU'RE
LEAVING.
HOW YOU DO THAT FROM THE
COMMENTS WE'RE GONE AS OF
TUESDAY THE 31st OF AUGUST.
WITH REGARD TO THE PEACE TREATY
HERE IT IS.
IT'S SIX PAGES IN LENGTH.
IT WAS SIGNED ON
FEBRUARY 29th, 2020 WHICH WAS
A SATURDAY, LEAP DAY IN A LEAP
YEAR.
YOU KNOW WHAT ALSO HAPPENED THAT
DAY?
SOUTH CAROLINA PRIMARY THAT
CATAPULTED JOE BIDEN TO THE HEAD
OF THE DEMOCRATIC PRIMARY.
IN THE AGREEMENT IT STATES FOUR
PARTS TO IT.
ONE OF THEM MENTIONED FOUR TIMES
INTRA AFGHAN NEGOTIATIONS
BETWEEN BOTH SIDES.
THE AFGHAN GOVERNMENT AND THE
TALIBAN.
FOR WHATEVER REASON.
BLAME WHO EVER YOU WANT TO BLAME
THAT DIDN'T HAPPEN ACCORDING TO
THIS DEAL.
>> JESSE.
>> HE DOES HAVEN'T TO GO BY THE
TRUMP AFGHAN DEAL.
HE SHREDDED SO MANY TRUMP DEALS.
NOW HE HAS TO DO WHAT TRUMP DID.
I'M NOT TPWHAOEUG.
THE HEADLINE HE'S STICKING TO
THE HEADLINE.
ANOTHER HEADLINE HE WILL DO
WHATEVER IT TAKES TO KILL THE
SUCKERS AND RESCUE EVERY
AMERICAN STRANDED.
IN GENERAL THE VIBE WAS OFF.
LABORED BREATHING.
AT ONE MOMENT HE WAS CRYING.
THEN HE WAS LIKE JOHN WAYNE
GETTING TOUGH.
I COULDN'T TELL WHAT WAS GOING
ON.
HE SAID IT WAS NOT A MISTAKE TO
PUT THE TALIBAN IN CHARGE OF
BEING OUR BODYGUARDS.
NOT A MISTAKE.
WOULDN'T DO IT ANY OTHER WAY.
THEN HE WENT OUT OF HIS WAY TO
DO TWO THINGS DEFENSIVELY IN MY
OPINION.
HE EXPLICITLY SAID HOW ENGAGED
HE WAS AND BRIEFED.
HE KNOWS THE PERCEPTION IS HE'S
DISENGAGED.
NUMBER TWO THE COMMANDERS ALL A
TKPWRAOEU, EVERYONE IS IN
AGREEMENT.
THERE IS NO DISAGREEMENT.
I'M NOT BUYING THAT.
I BELIEVE THERE IS DISAGREEMENT
ESPECIALLY RETAKING THE AIR
BASE.
HE PUT THAT ON THE GENERALS.
THEY DON'T WANT TO RETAKE IT.
YOU HAVE FIVE DAYS TO HIT THE
DEAD LINE AND FIVE THOUSAND
TROOPS.
ALL AND ALL HE SAID A KOUFPL
GOOD THINGS OFF A TELEPROMPTER.
I'M NOT CONVINCED HE MEANS THEM.
HE HAS SHREDDED IS CREDIBILITY
BEING WRONG AND NOT TOUGH
ENOUGH.
>> TO FOLLOW-UP AND THEN I WILL
LET IT GO TO GREG.
WE LEFT THE AIR BASE JULY 6th,
2021.
THE SAME WEEK JOE BIDEN SAID THE
TALIBAN HA H. A LOW CHANCE OF
TAKING OVER THE COUNTRY.
NOW HE SAID HE DOESN'T WANT TO
REOPEN, IT WASN'T A MILITARY
ASSET FOR US.
WE DIDN'T PLAN THIS MASS
EVACUATION AND AIRLIFT.
THEY TOUT AS A SUCCESS.
WHY ARE WE DOING AN AIRLIFT.
THE TIME LINE --
>> THEY VERY MUCH WANT CREDIT
FOR THE AIRLIFT.
EVEN REPORTERS COVERING THE
WHITE HOUSE.
WE GET IT YOU WANT CREDIT FOR
THE AIRLIFT.
WE WANT PEOPLE TO GET OUT.
GREG, HE SAID HE'S GETTING
EVERYONE OUT.
HE DIDN'T STALK ABOUT RESOURCES.
>> YES I DON'T KNOW HOW YOU
FIGHT WHILE YOU RUN AWAY.
HOW DO YOU HUNT AND WITH DRAW AT
THE SAME TIME.
YOU KNOW WHO INSTRUCTED HIM.
WHO INSTRUCTED HIM TO PICK THE
REPORTERS.
I HAVE BEEN INSTRUCTED.
WAS THAT ALSO THE TALIBAN.
>> JUST CALL ON THEM.
>> I HAVE BEEN INSTRUCTED.
IMMEDIATELY WHEN HE SAYS THAT
YOU PUT IT IN THE FACT HE LOOKS
DEFEATED.
IT'S LIVING, YOU DON'T HAVE THE
FEEL OF CONFIDENCE.
MAYBE HE'S SAD BUT HE SOUNDED
DEFEATED AND TIRED.
THERE WASN'T, THERE WAS A FLASH
OF ANGER HERE AND THERE.
THE OTHER THING I HAVE NEVER, I
NEVER TRUST ANYBODY THAT SAYS
CON CENSUS.
WHEN YOU ASK YOU SAY THERE WAS A
CONCENSUS.
THAT MEANS IT WAS A BAD IDEA YOU
GET THE WORST IDEA WITH
CONCENSUS.
>> KATIE, NOT DEFEATED AND TIRED
IS ISIS AND TALIBAN.
>> THE TALIBAN LET ISIS AND AL
QAEDA OUT OF THE PRISON.
ELIMINATING THE RESPONSIBILITY
FROM THE TALIBAN WON'T FLY WHEN
IT COMES 209 FACTS.
>> ONE LAST THING, DA NA.
I THINK EVERY FLAG AROUND THIS
COUNTRY, IMMEDIATELY, EVERY
CAPITOL AROUND THE WORLD SHOULD
BE LOWERED IN MEMORY OF THE
MARINES WE LOST TODAY.
THEY GAVE THEIR LIVES FOR THE
ULTIMATE SACRIFICE.
HELPING AN ASPECT OF HUMANITY
THAT NEEDED IT DEARLY.
THOUSANDS AND THOUSANDS STILL
NEED THE HELP.
GOD BLESS THEM.
>> THEY WILL CONTINUE TO CARRY
OUT THIS MISSION.
AS TREY SAID THEY HAVE TO RETRO
TKPW